ich glaube dass da viel viel rum
gewischt wird viel augenwischerei
betrieben wird jetzt nicht sie
persönlich aber ich glaube in der
bundesregierung hat speziell
ich weiß es nicht es wird sich zeigen
warum ende des tages muss der mensch da
irgendwie mit an denn ich glaube dass
wir nicht viel einfluss haben was meinen
sie mit der augenwischerei was da
passiert ich glaube es lag ja ich finde
ich finde auch die vergangenheit mit
corona und auch die flüchtlingswelle zu
15 da wurde viel vieles geredet vieles
versprochen vieles wurde nicht geändert
man hat es dann der herr hat's ja auch
angesprochen von der polizei dass da man
halt man wusste 215 wie es abgelaufen
ist mach das jetzt wiederum genauso mehr
oder weniger es wird einfach da wird
geredet man ein wildes machen es gibt
prozesse die gegen klein eingeleitet
werden dass wir trotzdem nicht vollzogen
von daher ich habe da so ein bisschen
glauben an die politik grundsätzlich
verloren muss ich ehrlich sagen weil da
einfach vieles auch einfach nicht
umgesetzt wird was dann versprochen wird
oder es wird dann wieder nach dem
wahlkampf wieder umgeworfen damit es
wieder doch revidiert und man muss ein
kompromiss eingehen wo ich nicht okay
man muss ja irgendwie mal standhaft sein
in seinen alten
[Musik]